[Music]
good afternoon
like Wendy I grew up in a very abusive
environment taught me to think that
violence was a way of dealing with
problems getting your respect it became
normal to me so I thought with the
cultural influences I got in the gangs
and that created a bad way of
destructive behavior that led me to
getting in a fight and another person
got hurt from another person which was a
self-defense situation but because I
didn't testify the ended up giving me 16
years to life in prison
so my mentality even then was I had to
own up to it and as much as I could
understand it
I thought fighting was normal and I
thought it was just gonna be a normal
fight in California it's the felony
murder rule and you can you can be
sentenced to life in prison under the
ADA in the bedding and so I had this
pessimistic view living in in prison
thinking that I'll never get out and I
ended up getting a life sentence on top
of another life sentence in maximum
maximum security housing which allowed
me to sit in my cell for eight hours a
day or sometimes even 12 hours a day
just studying philosophy psychology
history languages and I came across this
passage from Nietzsche that said for
thou has had a bad day but still see
that it worse evening does not overtake
thee and why he wrote that was when he
entered into the German prisons he's
seen all his fellow German
just sitting around not really trying to
do anything with their lives and so he
talked about the ubermensch which under
my interpretation was to try to be the
best person that you can be and so I
even even that during that time I was
studying the Bible and when I came
across the subject today where were to
speak of hope and optimism I mean hope
to me in my opinion is the main
component - one of the main components
to a successful prayer and because I had
hope became optimistic believed that I'd
get out I ended up getting out I
visualized a lot of things and
everything I visualized everything I
hope for has come and I I was sitting in
the audience and and having the
philosopher stand here and talk about
deep hope I mean to be in there telling
50 other lifers I'm not I'm not going to
be dying in prison I'm gonna end up
getting out that's deep hope especially
when it comes out your mouth but I'm a
strong believer of curse and blessings
rather than curse my life I rather
blessed my life and
[Applause]
and I believe if you think it you're
gonna behave it and if you behave it
it's gonna become an attitude and
because of that attitude it allowed me
not to think that I know it all but an
even though when I was young I knew I
didn't know nothing at all was
uneducated I want to live my life that I
don't know it at all and I want to learn
and so when I came across the actors
gang I took it I went with it they even
asked me to put makeup on the men call
it man cake and it's a humbling
experience and there's things that such
as we live by a model in the actors gang
which is we're a master of our thoughts
not a victim of our minds and I talked
with my girlfriend about that all the
time where when we're in discussions I
mean it took a long time to become that
person that I was it took around a good
10 years to become the person I was but
it it took 22 years of my incarceration
to make me the person that I am today
and so transformation and this magnitude
isn't a revolution but an evolution and
so with the actors gang allowing me the
witness anger allowing me to witness
fear sadness and happiness and as you
look in the video happiness and anger is
easy to accept in prison but when it
comes to fear when it comes to sadness
we live this mighty small thing and in
prison and it's looked down upon him
amongst men but actually in some
cultures - it's it's also looked as
machismo but the real machismo accepts
those emotions
we'll change the kids diapers will cook
and so when it came to the actors gang
allowing me to face fear acknowledge
fear acknowledge sadness it made me more
humane it made me more human so when I
have to cry out cry and that's prop it's
processing those emotions it's not
allowing me to be numb with with with
things that are going on because
suffering it's inevitable you're gonna
witness broken relationships are gonna
witness death you're gonna witness
losing a job but now when I deal with
these things I mean there's a lot of
things that are not just dealing with
your emotions but like Chris Bingley was
saying it's understanding how to work as
a team - that helped me to survive out
here in society for the last two years
and help me to be successful because in
the actors gang you better just be ready
to pick up the slack you better be ready
to pick up the slack and because I was
able to pick up the slack it allowed me
to get into a union in construction
allowed me to be successful in the
construction field and made me humble to
accept the teachings of other people and
I'm very grateful for the actors gang
for allowing me to be a student and and
I look forward to having some more
engagements like this thank you
[Applause]
these are the people were incarcerating
for ridiculous amounts of time why we
have to stop and let's not allow what's
happening in DC to let lets go back to
tough on crime it never worked and it
will never work this is what works
[Applause]
[Music]